the fbi has raided donald trump's estate
in florida in an unprecedented swoop on
the home of a former american president
trump claims agents broke into his safe
at the mar-a-lago complex he's already
under investigation for allegedly
removing official records from the white
house but trump claims the raid is aimed
at preventing him from running for
president again in 2024
palm beach florida
this is the scene that followed the
first ever fbi search of the next
president's home
outside this luxury resort owned by
donald trump his fan base is rallying in
protest
they believe the fbi is carrying out a
political agenda
by the administration the democrats are
weaponizing the fbi and it has to stop
it and i don't understand why the fbi
came because what's in there in coming
to this president's house someone who we
love a lot who we know is the only
person who can save this country we
don't want to be like cuba like
nicaragua like venezuela
venezuela
the ex-president drummed up his
republican base after saying his estate
was raided in a statement on a social
media channel truth social warning of
dark times in america trump said the
raid was not necessary or appropriate
and said the fbi broke open his safe
trump is under scrutiny by the
department of justice for allegedly
violating the presidential records act
of 1978
legislation that makes it illegal to
remove any documents from the white
house
penalties for breaking the records law
include disqualification from holding
federal office
dw's washington bureau chief innes poll
has been tracking the story i asked her
how serious this could be for donald
trump
well rebecca this has never happened
before in the history of the united
states so
one can assume that the fbi has good
reasons to believe that they will find
classified documents at the property
which might prove that the com that the
former president that donald trump
committed a crime but
time is on the side of donald trump as
it will take months if not years before
the president might be prosecuted and
republicans already said that they will
start a committee to investigate the
surge and any ruling rebecca will
definitely be escalated to the next
court so short answer no it is actually
very unlikely that we will see him
beared from running for office quite the
opposite might happen that this will
give him actually a boost to announce
him running very soon
now trump says this is all part of an
effort by democrats to weaponize the
justice system against him uh is there
any evidence of that
now at this point there is no evidence
that the fbi is being weaponized by
anybody it actually is quite interesting
uh that the current fbi
chief christopher wray was appointed by
donald trump himself even so they had a
fallout over some
russia
issues but however stakes for the
investigators again
are really high so
it would be really really very bad uh if
later emerges that the fbi search was
not conducted by the books and i think
the officials are very aware of that
what does this say then about the state
that the country finds it itself in at
the moment i mean with the midterm
elections just around the corner
right we will have midterm elections uh
in actually really three months pretty
much to the day well it is quite
remarkable that donald trump himself
broke the news about the search on a
social media platform and he used uh
the typical
words to really trigger fear and anger
with him within his fans you know
rebecca i'm just coming back from cpac
this is the annual meeting of the far
right republican branch and it was super
obvious there that every republican who
dares to criticize donald trump will be
punished and politically destroyed so it
doesn't really come as a surprise that
everybody who is criticizing donald
trump or is coming after donald trump is
seen as someone is coming after
the republican party so there's a lot of
support for donald trump after the
search even more so than before
right dw washington bureau chief innes
paul thanks very much
my first guest tonight worked for the
fbi for more than 20 years and he is the
author
of the book compromised
counterintelligence and the threat of
donald j trump which became a new york
times and washington post best seller
peter strzok joins me tonight from
washington mr strzok it's good to have
you on
the program
the image that the world is seeing fbi
agents armed with a search warrant
searching the residence of a former u.s
president for people outside the united
states what is the message that they
should be reading in this
well i think it's a rather extraordinary
message and on the one hand it's a very
positive message on the other hand it's
a very concerning one in the concerning
context this is the first time that a
search warrant has ever been served on a
president or former president of the
united states so this is truly the first
time you're seeing it the first time
we're seeing it i think from the good
news it's the the the observation that
in this united states there is no person
that's above the law that no matter if
it's a president or who it is that if
they violate the law if they are
maintaining in this case apparently
classified information that the
government is going to go get a search
warrant and recover it
this search warrant
would not have been issued without a
federal judge and i'm assuming also the
attorney general the head of the fbi all
thinking that there's they probably will
find something inside mar-a-lago can we
say then that donald trump is now closer
to being possibly charged with the crime
than he's ever been before
well i don't know it's certainly
significant that in this case you know
in the united states justice system a
search warrant
has to be done between two branches of
government within the executive branch
the department of justice the attorneys
the investigators at the fbi build a
case but they cannot obtain a warrant on
their own they have to go to a separate
judge which is different from the
executive branch they have to present an
affidavit which lays out facts not only
that there is probable cause which in
the u.s legal system means that there's
a a
reasonable belief that there is evidence
of a crime but that it's also evidence
of a crime that exists right now now
there's a big difference still between
having that search warrant potentially
obtaining and recovering classified
information and then reaching the next
hurdle to bring charges because that's
at a much higher standard that's proof
beyond a reasonable doubt so you go from
uh you know 60 70 percent level of
belief way way much higher i think it's
fair to say that if you look in the
context of what donald trump is facing
now whether it's the search at
mar-a-lago whether it's the material
that's being uncovered by the january 6
committee whether it's the criminal
investigation that is going on within
the department of justice about all the
various actions around january 6 whether
that's the the insurrection at the
capitol whether it's this very broad
attempt to create a fake slate of
electors in several states and of course
looking at some of the the tax
investigations within new york state i
think it's fair to say that donald trump
has not faced criminal exposure of this
magnitude before in his life and trump
immediately lashed out last night at the
fbi which he's done before i mean he
called the search um a raid in a broken
third world country what went through
your mind when you heard that
well
my initial thought is there is no
president who has done more to attempt
to turn the united states into a failed
state than former president trump i mean
look the fact of the matter is
when you look at the behavior
historically of every american president
there's a clear outlier in terms of
their disregard of not only the practice
and you know sort of normative behavior
of u.s presence but frankly
simple avoidance and disregard of the
law of the united states whether that's
the actual written law or whether it's
the intent of the law and we see that in
everything from his inability to retain
communications whether he's flushing him
down the toilet or eating them whether
he and his cabinet officials are being
accused of multiple violations of
political expression by holding rallies
on white house grounds there has never
been a president who has done more to to
scoff and break down the laws and
traditions of the presidency so to the
extent he has complaints about what the
us has become
it's complaints about the us that he
helped create and this represents the
things we're seeing in the search
warrant an attempt to re-establish the
rule of law in the united states and and
i'm wondering how long that attempt can
last and i'm thinking about the the
midterm elections coming up in november
if the republicans win control of
congress you know there were threats
made in the last 24 hours of an
investigation into
the department of justice because of
this
raid are you worried about the fbi
becoming a target after november
absolutely i'm worried about the fbi i'm
worried about the department of justice
i'm worried about any branch or subunit
of the u.s government that is perceived
as hostile to trump's or trump's
interests and are not insufficiently
friendly to his uh to his friends i mean
look there is a real possibility that
one or both chambers of the us congress
will flip from democratic to republican
in the vote which occurs in november the
the new congress would be sworn in in
january so that really creates a you
know somewhat short timetable it won't
stop the efforts of the department of
justice but i think there's an
extraordinary amount that the u.s
congress can do to slow down and gum up
the works of what the department of
justice in particular is doing and i
think they're willing to do that in a
way that we've never seen before done in
the united states
i want to get your opinion before we run
out of time here about what we heard
today from
former u.s vice president mike pence he
tweeted about an hour ago
i share the deep concern of millions of
americans over the unprecedented search
of the personal residence of president
trump no former president of the united
states has ever been subjected to a raid
of their personal residence in american
history
he's outraged that this has happened to
donald trump um and there are many who
say that donald trump was willing to let
him be hanged on
january 6.
how do you make sense of that
well yeah that's exactly right i mean
the fact of the matter is as you
indicated there has been no vice
president in united states history who
the president called for them to be
hanged as they sat there trying to do
their duty in a safe location within a
capital that was under attack so i you
know clearly vice president pence has an
eye to his political future i don't know
how he expects on the one hand cozy up
to president trump and on the other hand
just you know two and a half short years
ago was subjected to a mob seeking to
lynch him i don't know that he threads
that needle successfully at the end of
the day but you know it's clear that
he's decided as best he can he's going
to cast his political lot with former
president trump i don't expect it's
going to work out well for him but we'll
see we'll see how that evolves yeah it's
definitely a hard one to understand
that's for sure
peter strzok we appreciate your time and
your insights tonight thank you
thank you
and for more now i'm joined by jennifer
taub she's an author and law professor
at western new england university school
of law and she joins me tonight from
northampton in massachusetts professor
it's good to have you with us tonight
this is the first time in u.s history
that the fbi has
raided the home of a former president do
we know what led the justice department
to take this stunning step
thanks for having me according to news
accounts
we believe that this search warrant was
sought in order to find documents
that the former president apparently
pilfered from the white house back when
he
uh departed in january of 2021
apparently he had returned about 15
boxes
a year later when asked but not
everything uh came back
and there's a concern professor isn't
there that there's classified
information in these documents and if
that is the case then taking those
documents outside of the white house
when you're no longer a u.s president
that's a crime isn't it
yes but this has to be more than that
because in order to be able to execute
to get a judge to approve a search
warrant you would need to believe that
there was a cri ongoing crime
that the search would result in finding
evidence of that crime on site and that
a regular subpoena would not
work plus you really have to convince
the judge that something fresh or new
has happened so it seems that most of
the legal experts believe it's not
merely his possessing of these documents
but a true concern that he is or has
used them um or distributed them in an
additionally unlawful way perhaps and
again this part is speculation that they
fear he was going to sell or share them
or
give them to somebody or give access to
somebody to these top secret documents
and that would be you know an imminent
uh
crime or an ongoing crime they might be
concerned about
and we know that there are several
investigations into
donald trump's time as u.s president but
with this
raid at mar-a-lago
can we say is it possible to say that he
is perhaps
closer to being charged with a crime
than he's been before
absolutely you could say that given that
our attorney general garland has been
exceedingly careful and cautious and is
known to cross every t and dot every eye
it's highly unlikely that this would be
the first step
into a criminal investigation and as for
the other investigations that the grand
jury or grand juries are looking at
it's possible that this particular
search could yield relevant evidence in
the united states
if there is a lawful search such as this
one pursuant to
an approved search warrant there's this
notion of something called the plain
sight rule so if they happen to come
across in the documents or locations
that they have authorized to search
other evidence
pertaining to these other investigations
that could lead us farther um toward
toward uh you know criminal consequences
in those as well i want to ask you
before we run out of time what do you
make of donald trump's accusations and
we've also heard this from
some republican members of congress that
what we're seeing here is a plot by the
democrats to prevent donald trump from
running for president again and that
they're using the justice department to
do this
is it possible that this is a weaponized
politicization of the justice department
that we're seeing
i very much doubt that today or
yesterday would have been the worst
possible day to do something political
joe biden had a week long
of you know great results his approval
ratings were up he got this massive
legislation passed and not only that
donald trump running would be ideal
there's no way he could possibly win
um anyway so this is not you know the
white house did not know about this
local law enforcement didn't know about
this uh merrick garland
and the fbi kept this very close
this is not something that was a
political decision
professor jennifer taub we appreciate
your time and your valuable insights
tonight thank you
thank you good night
you